let me see something on the grill
playing of all time
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
you know what's funny I'm just in pain
because of my back flashback sorry I
hurt my back I'm just being in an
awkward position rolling my ass I think
that's where the pains go yeah that was
the left side oh God one season later
it's my back that's like killing me
though I loosened it up just did a ton
of exercises and something clearly
worked because it feels a little loose
so what excites you the most about
artificial intelligence that it's going
to allow people to spend more time on
more meaningful critical things
day-to-day tasks we've had a ton of
focus on what jobs will it eliminate I'm
more interested in what jobs are they
going to create I think it's going to
impact the world greatly just like the
internet did just like the automobile
did just like airplane did just like the
radio did just like the printing press
did just like the telephone did the cell
phone big Technologies impact the world
and they create tons of great things and
create new challenges and I think humans
are up for the task looking forward to
this future enjoy it
I'll see you there
[Music]
love y'all have the best week hi hi I am
so excited I know that we don't have
that much time I'm ready to rock and
roll hasser smash chat GPT smash focus
groups of 100 people smash lemonade
double smash it's how I learned business
fake it till you make it mentality yes
there's a lot of value in it but I think
it's misunderstood when you're faking it
till you make it there's a level of
manipulation going on let me wear the
suit I mean there's a lot of lying that
comes along with it have conviction that
you're gonna make it act as if very
different than fake it to you make it
which comes with a lot of baggage of
like sleazy behavior that actually can
become very dangerous because you can't
become used to it and then when you make
it some of those things that got you
there with the faking it actually become
your scarlet letter and your
vulnerability of losing it so fake it to
you make it may lead to you losing it
but have conviction that you're going to
make it and acts that act as it becomes
a healthier version of it thank you for
having me on thank you thank you
ocean
[Music]
view where is it gone from
from yeah like what's the diagnosis yeah
what do you think um a lot better
because I know what it is now and I know
what I have to do so instead of what
I've been doing I'm gonna be doing this
a lot
I just tweeted it what is it the liars
lumbar or whatever maybe it's time to
start playing soccer
now it's called football
foreign
hi what do you worry about let's start
with that building the biggest building
like you say here's the good news if
somebody copies you directly and is
slightly better at Tick Tock content
than you and that was what mattered
you're not gonna stop them anyway what
are you gonna sit and fume with her over
dinner or with your dad and that's
that's not gonna stop them you can't
stop winners so you got to let winners
win too and you just got to focus on
being the best winner like when Kobe was
like working out at midnight it wasn't
like he was sending somebody to like
stop Iverson from working out he could
only focus on what he focused on
honestly brother it creates a great life
like when I think about the other young
business men and women that have come up
during my era I'm so happy because I
know a lot of them and a lot of them do
spend their time [__] on the other
ones and I'm like oh he's fascinated by
like you won what are we spending 20
minutes of this dinner [__] on a
third person that's also one like that's
a waste of time it's just bad energy
it's a complete waste of time let's
sneak this
can only move one spot
reply to the bitter ends of death
I'm not scared
great job brother this was really
enjoyable it's good to see you
[__] pissed
I think I got over aggressive too early
cause me
a little more patient last time I let
him make the mistakes
losing
oh my God that was not good
I just lost some Checkers after I after
I beat him last year so I'm a little bit
salty this is the first time
watch this let me see some of the great
you know playing of all time green huge
mistake
[__] just take that just take that nice
work you did this
um
Uno you can't play you can't play you
can't play
Uno game over
I just want to be known that I said this
was gonna be one of the Great
Performances let me see some of the
Great
of all time I need that completely
broken down that was quick perfect
timing for a social media post and if
you were on the cards a ridiculous back
and forth we're back look at this [__]
look at this [__]
[Music]
it's a profound time but there is
something about the AI that all seems
obvious it's going this way and there's
some macro counter thing like will we
become more human because of it you know
it's like you see where I'm going like
we'll have more time to be focusing on
our EQ skills with each other because
the IQ is being like school is a
disaster I was mad that they were doing
it for the last 20 years with the
internet now we have ai like read Lord
of the Flies and give me critical
thinking about it and like there's the
answers probably better than what the
teacher thinks is the answer then it
becomes a game of like chai GPT overlay
Lord of the Flies with Goonies with on
my block from Netflix in the voice of
Will Smith like this becomes like
I mean I might just sit in my room and
just do queries I've always
I've waited no I actually think it's the
reverse you're honing your skills
[Music]
we're so pleased to have him back please
welcome Gary vaynerchuk
I can hear you I can see all the
beautiful young faces I'm feeling ready
things like gratitude and kindness and
empathy like I get that everyone's foofy
about it I'm very aware of the culture
that we all live in I understand of like
the gender war on Tick Tock I understand
everything this is what I do for a
living I promise you these soft skills
wait to AI comes and eats up a ton more
of the IQ and the tangible and the black
and white we're only going to be left
with gray and these great skills are
going to be the differentiation for you
to get what you want period and so I I
hope you develop them Gary Vader
[Music]
thank you